[Music]
but it's only set to have a new prime
minister again I will work day in day
out to deliver for the British people
Rishi sunak will be the third person to
hold that title in the past seven weeks
it's been absolutely ridiculous
journalistically it's been kind of
amazing but the story for the country is
a very very depressing one
Mr sunax in tray is already piled high
what are his biggest challenges going to
be
in the short term the fact that we have
a new prime minister is a good thing Mr
sunac is a competent Orthodox fiscally
responsible figure the markets are
watching very closely to see what
Britain does next and he is reassuring
the immediate reaction to Mr sunax
elevation has been the sigh of relief
the pound has strengthened guilt yields
have dropped so that is that is good
however it is just very very difficult
for anyone to both reassure the markets
and deliver growth at this point the two
are working against each other in the
medium to long term his arrival in 10
Downing Street does not solve some of
the big structural problems that the
country faces
one is the state of the public services
and the National Health Service in
particular is really really straining so
over the summer we've seen winter-like
problems in terms of delays for
ambulances the backlog of people waiting
for treatment is up to 7 million now
which is extraordinary and as
temperatures drop sickness gets worse
over the next few months you can expect
that to worsen schools are another
example of where strains exist in the
public services so they have already
suffered a real terms cut in spending
because inflation is eating into the
settlement that that department got
teachers want to see their pay keep Pace
with inflation we have energy as another
thing which is bearing down on school
budgets he has to kind of keep the
country going through the winter and
that may sound overly dramatic but I
don't think it is we are going to have
strikes we're going to have a health
system under strain we're going to have
a recession we're going to have tension
with the bank of England and we have the
political instability that we've seen
already so those are big big issues
which will be worsened by the fact that
we have to reassure the markets that
Britain is committed to fiscal
responsibility politically as well a
series of extremely difficult decisions
now have to be taken we are going to
have to see a combination of tax Rises
and spending cuts which will exacerbate
all of the issues that I've just
described so he has to walk this very
narrow and difficult tightrope between
satisfying investors in Britain and
satisfying his voters
because Mr sunac has to run a party
which has proved itself almost
ungovernable because
the party is deeply unpopular and likely
to become more so as the decisions he is
about to make bite you could imagine yet
another round of infighting and at that
point the calls for a general election
even if constitutionally one is not
needed will become ever more difficult
to resist there is a question of moral
and Democratic legitimacy which is
already in the air another leadership
contest would make that almost
impossible to resist
thanks for watching to read more of our
coverage on British politics click the
link and don't forget to subscribe
foreign
[Music]